i do look forward to a time where it's
not a talking point i
hope that there gets to a point which i
think that will i feel like my story
through hollywood i'm happy that people
are following my story because it's
quite authentic
it's not contrived or anything and i
like being as real as i can be so
i feel like the stories that we create
then we'll release that like i can't
wait until the day that somebody asks me
about my dog that i just bought or the
three kids that i probably will have
or you know my soon-to-be husband
possibly with my boyfriend you know
i can't wait until people ask me about
that and it won't be just
a topic of discussion as far as my
transcends but instead
just my life as a human being and my
life as a woman and how i live within my
woman
look i don't like what lamar and the
house of khan is doing their tarnishing
ballroom
making it about money when it should
really be about creativity
community family everything we worked
hard to create and
don't y'all want to become iconic no
i already am it's emotional i
wouldn't say i'm i'm too sad because we
did so much
for the community we did so much great
work on the show i wouldn't say i'm sad
i'm empowered but um
i'm very emotional it's
kind of surreal and crazy to see all the
work that we've done
come to an end but in a good way um
i'm just so excited i'm happy i think
people saw the ballroom scene as just
uh just a hideaway and it wasn't that i
think the ballroom scene first it
started
long before the 80s and it really
it really encompassed trans women
literally living like they were going to
a ball like the actual
actual traditional ball then it evolved
as
all things do um but it was a place for
people
to not only find solace in themselves
with my source and other people and
find comfort and find joy in the people
that they saw like them
the house with the most sickening
presentation in
face runway and vogue will not only walk
away with a trophy this evening
but your esteemed m.c council has cash
that's a thousand dollars to be exact
like blanca is the true depiction of
what someone
is when they have a starting point and
when they reach their ending point and
it's
a good outcome she's that depiction of
that and also she's
love she's hope she instills all of that
not to mention on top of all of this
it encompasses with her being a mother
and being a black latina trans woman
many people don't think that's possible
many people think that we're not capable
of doing that right
but with blanca i think a lot of people
see that
she's capable of doing that i think
that's what the legacy is she's
raising not only uh
the community in a way but with even
with her kids she's raising resilient
children which shows that she's a great
mother so um
yeah there's so much growth i think that
people love the growth of blanca and i
think they love that she's a go-getter
and that she doesn't stop